[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition des matins du sénat
vous l'ignorez peut-être mais le sénat
enquête depuis plusieurs mois sur la
privatisation des autoroutes en france
la décision a été actée en 2005 par le
gouvernement de villepin
et c'est justement en qualité de
directeur de cabinet du premier ministre
de l'époque que bruno le maire a été
auditionné au sénat cette semaine selon
lui oui l'opération financière a été
réussie deuxième audition à suivre
aujourd'hui celle d'alexis colère le
secrétaire général de l'elysée il était
en 2015 le directeur de cabinet des
manuels macron alors ministre de
l'économie
il sera question de la renégociation des
contrats avec les sociétés autoroutières
et de la flambée des prix des tarifs qui
avait suivi direction la salle médicis
pour suivre cette audition préparer
aujourd'hui pour public sénat par louis
mollier sa baie et mathilde mutarelli
bien mes chers collègues je vous propose
d'ouvrir notre séance du jour monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur le rapporteur nous poursuivons
nos auditions sur les concessions
autoroutières en entendant monsieur
bruno le maire en sa double qualité de
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la relance et en qualité d'ancien
directeur de cabinet de monsieur
dominique de villepin premier ministre
de 2006 à 2007 au moment de la
privatisation des sociétés d'autoroutes
premier ministre de villepin que nous
avons eu l'occasion d'auditionner la
semaine dernière cette audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du sénat
elle est également ouverte à la presse
et fera l'objet d'un compte rendu publié
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie de
vous être vendue à notre convocation et
après avoir rappelé qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
denquête est passible des peines prévues
aux articles 344 134 13,4 134,14 434 15
du code pénal je vous invite à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité levé la main droite et dit je
le jure je le jure je vous remercie
donc avant de passer la parole à notre
rapporteur vincent de l'est qui vous
posera des questions précises comme à
son habitude et aux membres de la
commission denquête présents dans cette
salle médicis
je vous propose si vous le souhaitez
bien sûr de nous présenter à titre
liminaire le rôle que vous avez joué
lors de la privatisation des sociétés
d'autoroutes en 2016
en 2006 pardon votre appréciation sur ce
choix et et nous y reviendrons sans
doute la façon dont vous voyez l'
équilibre des relations entre l'état et
les sociétés concessionnaires
d'autoroutes et l'avenir de la gestion
du réseau autoroutier l'actualité et
danse vous proposons d'ouvrir une
parenthèse et de vous replonger dans le
passé et d'ouvrir aussi un regard vers
l'avenir
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messiers des sénateurs c'est avec un
grand plaisir que je me replonge en
arrière dans mes anciennes fonctions de
directeur de cabinet du premier ministre
dominique de villepin pour défendre des
choix qui reste cohérent avec ma vision
de la politique économique et du rôle de
l'état dans l'économie
il y a quinze ans le premier ministre
dominique de villepin dont j'étais le
directeur de cabinet décide est sous
l'autorité du président de la république
jacques chirac de mener à son terme le
processus de cession des parts publiques
des sociétés concessionnaires
autoroutière l'objet de votre commission
denquête et d'évaluer ce choix et ses
conséquences mais aussi d'éclairer les
moyens à disposition de l'état pour
préserver ses intérêts vis-à-vis des
sociétés autoroutières et de préparer
l'avenir en anticipant la fin des
contrats de concession et éventuellement
en regardant comment renforcer la
régulation qui va avec ces contrats
avant de rentrer dans le vif du propos
je voudrais répondre à quatre questions
qui me paraissent essentiels
première question pourquoi est ce que
nous avons réalisé
et cette cession des parts publiques des
sociétés concessionnaires autoroutière
l'ancien premier ministre dominique de
villepin vous a je crois répondu
précisément mais je voudrais avant c'est
à mon tour
trois raisons principales qui d'ailleurs
m'avait amené non pas il ya 15 ans mais
il ya quelques mois à défendre le projet
de privatisation de la société française
des jeux ou d'aéroports de paris
la première raison c'est la
clarification du rôle de l'état dans
notre économie et ça me paraît un enjeu
qui reste tout à fait essentiel
aujourd'hui l'état était à la fois
actionnaire et concédant il était donc
dans un mélange des rôles qu'il me
paraît ni sain ni efficace pour la bonne
gestion de l'entreprise et pour la
défense des intérêts publics
nous voulions donc que l'état se
concentre uniquement sur ses missions de
concédant nous pensions et je continue
de penser que l'état n'a pas pour rôle
de gérer des autoroutes ou des péages et
je continue à le penser pour d'autres
grandes infrastructures
même si la crise a mis et cette question
et de côté aujourd'hui le rôle de l'état
c'était de bâtir ses autoroutes
il l'a fait le rôle de l'état c'est de
moderniser les transports et les
infrastructures
il l'a fait le rôle de l'état c'est de
garantir la bonne circulation des
marchandises et des personnes pour
industrialiser la france accélérer les
échanges et lier des français entre il
l'a fait et il doit continuer à le faire
quand nous plaidons pour le déploiement
rapide des infrastructures de 5 g ça
correspond exactement à ce rôle
hier c'étaient des autoroutes
aujourd'hui c'est la 5g et de la fibre
optique
mais c'est exactement le même rôle de
l'état auquel je suis profondément
attaché celui qui garantit la bonne
circulation non seulement des
marchandises et des personnes mais aussi
des informations des données désormais à
travers tout le territoire pour qu'il
n'y ait pas des territoires hier enclavé
et d'autres bien relié et aujourd'hui
des territoires bien équipés en fibre
optique est dit
lisez et d'autres qui ne le serait pas
ça c'est le rôle fondamental de l'état
en revanche gérer des autoroutes
s'assurer que les bandes d'arrêt
d'urgence sont bien entretenus ça c'est
pas le rôle de l'état et je continue à
penser que ce n'est pas le rôle de
l'état
de ce point de vue nous n'avons fait
d'ailleurs je le dis au passage que nous
inscrire dans la continuité de lionel
jospin ce qu'il n'y a eu absolument
aucune rupture de la part du premie de
l'époque qui n'a fait que mener à son
terme un processus engagé par l'ancien
premier ministre socialiste lionel
jospin
à partir de 2002 seules décisions
politiques qui était prise était de
céder la gestion pleine et entière de
tout le réseau autoroutier à des
entreprises privées
avec cette conviction que je continue de
partager 15 ans plus tard que ces
sociétés sont mieux à même mieux équipés
pour gérer les autoroutes que l'état est
mieux à même est mieux équipé pour
moderniser ce réseau deuxième raison
c'est que tout en confiant la gestion
des autoroutes les entreprises
spécialisées
nous avons conservé la propriété de
l'état
et je rappelle que c'était exactement le
même projet que nous avions que nous
continuons d'avoir pour aéroports de
paris s'agit pas de les aider ta la
propriété de terrains ou d'autoroutes
qui restent stratégiques ne faisons que
les concédé l'état je le rappelle est
toujours propriétaire des deux autres et
c'est un point absolument fondamental
nous n'avons fait que céder les parts de
l'état et sociétés qui sont chargés
d'exploiter les concessions
autoroutières et pour le public qui nous
écoute je pense que c'est un point
absolument fondamental car bien entendu
qui est essentiel que des tas reste
propriétaire des infrastructures
stratégiques
c'est le cas à la fin des contrats de
concession qui arriveront à leur terme
pour les sociétés concessionnaires
historique entre 2027 et 2050
l'état pourra s'il le souhaite récupérer
la gestion des infrastructures ou les
délégués de nouveau à des sociétés
concessionnaires puisqu'il reste
propriétaire de ces infrastructures
dans le même temps je rappelle que ces
infrastructures ont été entretenues et
modernisé
sur la base d'un cahier des charges sur
lequel j'aurai l'occasion de revenir
la troisième raison c'est que nous
voulions amorcer un changement dans la
stratégie de l'état actionnaire et ça
rejoint là encore des convictions que
j'ai défendue communiste l'économie et
des finances après les avoir défendues
comme directeur de cabinet de dominique
de villepin
nous voulions que les produits de
cession soit utilisé pour investir dans
l'avenir et se désendetter c'est
exactement ce que j'ai défendue aussi
pour la privatisation de la française
des jeux ou pour le projet sur aéroports
de paris
l'idée des biens désendetter massivement
le pays et dominique de villepin y est
arrivé avec son ministre des finances de
l'époque thierry breton et d'investir
dans l'avenir
c'est exactement la même logique qui
nous avaient amenés à privatiser en
novembre 2019
la française des jeux pour abonder un
fonds d'investissement et désendetter le
pays
la deuxième grande question qui se pose
après les raisons fondamentales qui nous
ont amené à prendre cette décision
c est ce que nous avons réussi cette
opération financière
oui l'opération financière a été réussi
s'agissant de la méthode
je pense qu'elle n'est pas critiquable
les opérations de privatisation ont
suivi une procédure stricte et
rigoureuse
elles ont donné lieu à des mises en
concurrence par appel d'offres organisé
par l' agence des participations de
l'état sous le contrôle commune va de
soi de la commission des participations
et des transferts
dix huit entités au total se sont
portées candidates
et cette méthode d'appels d'offres qui
évidemment beaucoup plus intéressante
que le gré à gré pour l'état nous a
permis d'obtenir le meilleur prix
la vente des parts publiques des
sociétés concessionnaires autoroutière a
rapporté près de 15 milliards d'euros à
l'état 14,8 précisément je sais qu'à
cour des comptes dans un rapport de 2009
a critiqué les conditions de cession
estimé que ces produits de cession
aurait pu être supérieur cela m'arrive
rarement mais je conteste ces critiques
m façon j'ai contesté les critiques de
la cour des comptes sur la mise en place
d'un fonds pour l'innovation dont je
continue à défendre la pertinence
je conteste les critiques sur les
modalités de cette cession des parts de
l'état
réalisé sous dominique de villepin
d'abord il ya un malentendu sur le
chiffre je n'y reviens pas je crois que
cela a déjà été expliqué longuement la
cour estimait qu'à valeur globale de
7000 km d'autoroutes étaient de 24
milliards d'euros or ces 24 heures de
rossel et 100% des parts des trois
sociétés concessionnaires
la société des autoroutes du nord et de
l'est de la france les autoroutes paris
rhin rhône et les autoroutes du sud de
la france et non la valeur des parts
détenues par l'état qui elle n'était pas
de 100%
enfin choix procédure je conteste ses
critiques également car j'estime que la
procédure a été respectée strictement
troisième série de questions quel bilan
est ce que nous pouvons dresser de ces
cessions d'actifs
d'abord si on est tout à fait honnête il
est impossible de faire un bilan
exhaustif pour le moment sur la
rentabilité obtenue par les entreprises
gestionnaires voyez bien qu'il suffit
qu'il y ait des événements totalement
imprévue crise des gilets jaunes crise
du coc vide pour que tout d'un coup la
rentabilité de ces sociétés d'autoroute
ne soient plus du tout la même
donc la rentabilité ne peut s'évaluer
qu'à la fin des concessions et ce serait
très présomptueux de pouvoir dire dès
maintenant sans savoir quelle nouvelle
crise peut arriver
quelle sera la rentabilité finale à la
fin des concessions seule chose que nous
pouvons dire c'est que à l'heure
actuelle le total des dividendes
actualisé s'appelle 2007 2018 est
inférieur au prix total de l'acquisition
de 14 et 2 8 milliards d'euros à ces
d'un fait mais ça ne préjuge pas de ce
que sera la situation
la fin des concessions je le reconnais
avec beaucoup d'humilité
nous pouvons en revanche dresser un
premier bilan pour les usagers et pour
le modèle de régulation des concessions
et là je pense qu'il ya effectivement
des leçons à tirer
premier indicateur la qualité de service
le réseau concédé est en meilleur état
que le réseau non concédé et c'est pas
une surprise parce que l'état n'est pas
outillée et n'est plus outillés et
d'ailleurs ne doit pas l'être parce que
je ne pense pas que ce soit sa
responsabilité principale pour
moderniser réparer adapté
un réseau autoroutier je ne pense pas du
tout que ce soit sa responsabilité
en 2010 7 83% du réseau concédé étaient
jugés en bonne ou en très bon état
contre seulement 12 % du réseau non
concédé et si des choses très concrètes
je le dis en usager régulier de la route
que je suis le télépéage à développer la
signalisation en temps réel a fait
d'immenses progrès l'impact
environnemental a été réduit plus de 400
aires d'autoroutes ont fait l'objet de
réaménagement lourd pour les rendre
accessibles aux personnes à mobilité
réduite pour fluidifier la circulation
pour mettre en place ce tri sélectif
pour mieux traiter les eaux usées
donc il ya d'investissement considérable
22 milliards d'euros d'investissements
qui ont été réalisés par les sociétés
concessionnaires depuis 2006
ces investissements sont d'ailleurs je
le rappelle suivi par l'état qui a pour
mission d'évaluer le réseau et la
qualité de service et grâce à des
indicateurs chiffrés dont le non-respect
peut entraîner des sanctions financières
donc sur ce point là nous avons et je
pense que ça peut être une fierté un des
réseaux autoroutiers les plus
performants au monde les plus modernes
au monde et qui sera très utile le jour
où se développeront des véhicules
autonomes parce que nous pourrons pour
faire fonctionner ces véhicules autonome
disposer d'un réseau autoroutier qui est
je le redis un des meilleurs aujourd'hui
au monde
en revanche peut se poser la question
des tarifs est ce que tout ça n'est pas
trop cher d'accord les autoroutes ce que
notre bon état mais ce que ce n'est pas
trop cher
est-ce que les tarifs vont augmenter oui
est ce que l'autoroute est chère pour
beaucoup nos compatriotes
oui est-ce que les tarifs se sont
envolés non je conteste pas que les
autoroutes soit cher pour nos
compatriotes
en revanche les tarifs ont augmenté en
suivant un rythme proche de celui de
l'inflation est conforme aux règles
prévues dans les contrats
la dernière question qui découlent de
ces interrogations sur les tarifs
c'est celle de la régulation équilibré
et je pense qu'il ya là matière à
amélioration sur ce point qui me paraît
tout à fait et sensible d'abord on peut
pas prévoir je vais déjà dit des
hypothèses de trafic sérieuse parce que
personne n'avait anticipé la crise du
coc vide personne n'avait anticipé
l'effondrement du trafic autoroutier
pendant plusieurs mois personne n'avait
anticipé la crise des gilets jaunes donc
les hypothèses sous-jacentes ne
permettait pas d'envisager ce genre
d'événement mais les hypothèses
sous-jacentes aux contrats ne prévoyez
pas non plus la baisse très forte des
taux d'intérêt qui a permis aux sociétés
concessionnaires de réduire leurs frais
financiers en refinançant leur dette à
des conditions plus favorables
ça c'est un point fondamental et je
pense que plutôt que de s'attarder sur
des sujets qui à mon avis sont de faux
sujet qualité d'autoroute est au rendez
vous les investissements ont été faits
les tarifs sont élevés mais ne se sont
pas envolés il y as havrais
enseignements à tirer de cette baisse
des taux d'intérêt qui a permis
effectivement d'un point de vue
financier aux sociétés concessionnaires
de réduire leurs frais financiers en
refinançant leur dette à des conditions
plus favorables
l'état essayé de corriger ce problème
par la suite avec le protocole de 2015
avec une clause limitant les surprofits
et avec le renforcement des prérogatives
de la rt mais je considère que c'est une
correction qui n'est pas suffisante
donc je considère qu' il faut maintenant
si nous retenons cette hypothèse une
poursuite des concessions renforcer la
régulation c'est un point absolument
essentiel pour tirer les leçons de ce
vide sur les taux d'intérêt qui n'avait
pas été anticipé dans la cession des
parts de l'état dans les concessions
autoroutières
nous avons besoin donc de faire des
points d'étape régulier
nous ne pouvons pas à fixer les
hypothèses d'évolution des prix du
trafic des investissements sur 30 40 ou
50 ans
donc nous avons besoin de faire des
points d'étape régulier c'est ce que
nous avions proposé par exemple dans le
cadre de la privatisation du groupe
aéroports de paris où nous avions
proposé d'inscrire dans les contrats des
clauses prévoyant des rendez vous tous
les cinq ans pour réévaluer les tarifs
suivent des investissements suivre les
prévisions de trafic et la rt se
prononçant à échéances régulières sur le
coût moyen pondéré du capital
deuxième conviction c'est que la nature
des contrats et des risques qui y sont
associés doivent évoluer les
renouvellement de concessions se feront
pour des actifs beaucoup plus mature que
les mises en concession historique
puisque les autoroutes sont déjà
construites la nature du risque est
différente il n'y a plus de risque
construction bien sûr les gestionnaires
devront gérer d'autres enjeux comme la
transition écologique et nouvelle
mobilité
il y aura toujours un risque à rémunérer
mais ce risque doit évoluer parce qu'il
est moins important que le risque lié à
la construction
enfin le dernier point ce que je ne
crois absolument pas à l'opportunité
d'une renationalisation de ces
autoroutes qui aurait un coût absolument
considérable pour les finances publiques
compris entre 45 et 50 milliards d'euros
qui serait très mauvais investissement
alors qu'ils ont besoin d'argent pour
investir dans l'innovation dans la
recherche et dans la souveraineté
technologique de notre pays donc je
crois que le modèle de délégation de
service public à des entreprises privées
a apporté la preuve de son efficacité
mais que la condition comme je lé
indiqué c'est que la régulation soit
améliorée notamment pour tenir compte
des questions de refinancement de la
dette par la société privée avec la
baisse des taux d'intérêt et leur
possible augmentation à l'avenir c'est
un point qui me paraît tout à fait
crucial
mais c'est monsieur le ministre votre
intervention liminaire précise mais je
ne doute pas que notre rapporteur va
vous demander quelques précisions
supplémentaires et quelques questions
aux également seront viendront de la
salle médicis où déjà des doigts se sont
levés
mon cher vincent vous avez la parole la
parole pardon merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
merci de ces propos prêt à la limite r
je dirais qu'ils ont eu exactement la
même durée de que ceux de monsieur de
villepin et qui n'ont eu que très peu
d'écart par rapport à ce qu'il a pu dire
sur le passé donc je vois que le
ministre était en phase avec son
directeur de cabinet et de ce point de
vue là c'est une bonne chose alors
quelques questions effectivement
complémentaires et puis comme je pense
qu'on va passer un peu de temps aussi
sur les pistes d'amélioration
juste sur le passé sur le prix la cour
des comptes effectivement évaluer les 24
milliards en fait c'est les sommes qui
ont été versés par les sociétés les
groupes qui ont racheté progressivement
en fait les les
des actions des sociétés d'autoroutes
puisque la première session a été faite
en 2002 par lionel jospin effectivement
qu'ensuite jean pierre raffarin s'est
opposé à des cessions supplémentaires et
que dominique de villepin lui a souhaité
et procédés or en réalité la cour des
comptes effectivement compare les 24
milliards dépensés au final par les
groupes pour acquérir les 100 % et les
100% que l'état possédait au départ
avant 2002 et c'est là où il ya quand
même un écart de entre les 15 milliards
et 24 milliards c'est la question c'est
pas simplement sur la période de la dite
de privatisation de 2006 c'est sur
l'ensemble de la période sur la
rentabilité des sociétés d'autoroutes
par rapport au gilet jaune
il ya eu très peu d'impact en fait quand
on regarde les rentabilités des années
2018 2019
c'est pas ses salles il n'y a pas
beaucoup aux contrats y presque
d'habiter en perpétuelle hausse et puis
l'épisode actuel avec la crise sanitaire
et
et toutes les conséquences qu'on en
connaît a priori devrait alors c'est
bien sûr c'est toujours au conditionnel
devrait voir une baisse de chiffre
d'affaires de 25% à peu près des
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroutes
et malgré cela ils vont dégager des
bénéfices arize rentabilité moindre
c'est certain c'est évident mais et
dégageront comme des bénéfices par
rapport à pas mal de sociétés d'activité
qui en france ou subir des conséquences
bien plus graves
ceci étant j'ai une question quand même
sur le passé c'est la question qu'on se
pose finalement de savoir pourquoi on
n'a pas modifié les contrats de l'époque
avant de céder des actions dire qu'on
avait des contrats quand même
historiquement
un peu anciens et est ce que justement
les histoires de point d'étape à
l'époque de parce que sur des
concessions à ses longues c'est vrai que
d'avoir des points d'étape régulier ça
sera été une bonne chose
pourquoi alors pour pour tout vous dire
que vous n'avez pas suivi sans doute son
audition mais dominique de villepin nous
a dit que il y avait déjà des sessions
qui avait été opérée effectivement sur
un sf je suis d'accord sur le fait qu'il
ya une première partition mais sur
d'autres il n'y avait pas une session
sur sa nef appert r je suis pas sûr en
tout cas on aurait pu qu'est-ce qui a
fait que s que c'est la précipitation
est ce que c'est le temps mais c'est
vrai que ça me ressemble et quand même
un peu souhaitable en tous cas que alors
deuxième question c'est sur la
rentabilité
vous dites est là un petit peu comme les
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroute il
faut attendre la fin des contrats re
tient de 2031 à 2036 pour constater la
rentabilité finale c'est bien mais ce
n'est pas très satisfaisant quand même
parce que comme on n'a pas de point
d'étape à moi qu'on réussisse à imposer
des points d'étape mais en l'absence de
point d'étape se dire que simplement à
la fin on constatera dès qu'on a une sur
en ta et hounsou rentabilité et
puis finalement mais les choses sont
comme ça c'est moi je trouve pas ça très
satisfaisant en tout cas dans les
auditions qu'on a pu avoir c'est un
sujet qui revient et sur la manière
d'évaluer effectivement dans le temps
cette rentabilité de la comparer avec ce
qui était attendu au départ par les
sociétés ce qui avait été annoncé ce qui
est servi de base aux prix je pense que
c'est quand même un sujet quoi je sais
pas quel est votre point de vue est ce
que est ce que vraiment on ne peut rien
faire sur le sujet où est-ce que et dans
l'équipe de la régulation entre les cons
sociétés concessionnaires et l'état
sociétés concessionnaires nous disent
bien sûr que l'état est trop fort trop
puissant
avec notamment bercy avec la cour des
comptes avec le conseil d'état avec
avec tout ça et que eux sont des pauvres
qui pauvre société qui ont du mal à se
défendre mais et qui sont très contrôlés
alors est ce que au delà des points
d'étape est ce qu'il ya des façons de
d'améliorer la régulation dans l'est
dans les onze 11 la saison qui nous
séparent de la fin des contrats pour
pour faire en sorte d'être peut-être pas
plus pointilleux ou
d'autres contrôles et plus souvent mais
contrôler mieux parce que finalement ce
qu'on recherchait de l'efficacité en
matière de contrôle et pas forcément de
l'exhaustivité
on a l'impression parfois le régulateur
est un peu dans l'exhaustivité puisque
dans l'efficacité
merci vincent monsieur le ministre vous
avez la parole pour répondre aux
questions de notre rapporteur
je commencerai par la dernière remarque
sur l'état trop puissant bercy trop
puissant qui est en game que j'entends
extrêmement souvent notamment de la part
d'entreprises qui se porte extrêmement
bien
donc nous irons pleurer sur ces
entreprises un autre jour je pense
qu'elle se porte très bien et je pense
que c'est le rôle de l'état
effectivement de défendre un équilibre
économique et que l'état n'est pas trop
puissants et que la crise actuelle au
contraire nous montre à quel point nous
avons besoin d'un état puissant d'un
ministère de l'économie et des finances
puissant pour faire face à la crise sur
la possibilité de revoir la régulation
avant de vendre les concessions aussi je
pense qu'il faut tirer les leçons des
erreurs qui ont pu être commises
nous sommes sous un régime de contrat
donc nous ne pouvons pas nous etat et
c'est la limite à la puissance dont je
viens de parler décidé unilatéralement
des modifications de contrats conclus
avec les sociétés d'autoroutes et quand
on se livrent à ce genre de facilités
on le paye très cher quand par exemple
un gel tarifaire a été décidée
unilatéralement en 2015
c'est sans doute très populaire mais
c'est totalement irresponsable parce
qu'au bout du compte on doit mettre en
place un rattrapage tarifaire coûteux
pour les usagers alors politiquement
c'est très habile c'est qu'on fait
croire aux français qu'on peut geler les
tarifs autoroutiers et puis on laisse
aux successeurs la note est l'addition
dire que deux ans trois ans plus tard
eh bien il faut compenser et faire un
rattrapage tarifaire coûteux pour les
usagers c'est pas ma conception de la
responsabilité politique
donc je pense que toute modification
unilatérale
contrat tel qu'elle a déjà été pratiqué
dans le passé est une erreur le deuxième
point absolument essentiel c'est de voir
ce qui peut être fait à travers la rt
sur la rentabilité chaque année des
sociétés la rt évalue le taux de retour
sur investissement
donc l'état peut décider d'activer les
clauses de sueur rentabilité qui sont
prévues par le protocole de 2015
ça c'est très concrètement la
possibilité qui nous est offerte avec
notamment la possibilité d'une réduction
de la durée des contrats je crois que ça
n'a jamais été utilisé je veux pas faire
d'erreur je crois que ça n'a jamais été
utilisée donc c'est pour moi la seule
disposition qui puisse être utilisée
parce qu'elle est prévue par le
protocole de 2015 s'est activé des
clauses de sueur rentabilité si on le
juge nécessaire mais je le redis en
restant dans le cadre du contrat tel que
modifié en 2015 pardon monsieur ministre
surtout si elle s'applique pas ce que
c'est 30 % de dépassement de du chiffre
d'affaires sur la base 2006 et
honnêtement c'est une clause qui a le
mérite d'exister mais qui en réalité
sera difficilement je partage totalement
vous en avoir un d'où ma troisième
remarque justement votre avis je pense
qu'elle sera difficile à utiliser à
déclencher en revanche sa confiance
devrait être un tout petit peu plus
précis ce que j'ai dit dans mon
intervention liminaire
la question clé c'est le taux de retour
sur investissement taux de retour sur
investissement prévus dans les contrats
et j'ai eu l'occasion de le reconnaître
pendant le débat sur adp a été prévu
dans le cadre des concessions
autoroutières ceux des durée trop longue
je pense que c'est la seule erreur que
nous ayons fait mais je la reconnais
bien volontiers parce que nous n'avions
pas anticipé la baisse les taux
d'intérêt donc la possibilité pour
associer d'autoroute de refinancer leurs
dettes d'intérêt beaucoup plus favorable
avec du coup un taux de retour sur
investissement beaucoup plus élevé le
coût du financement varie dans le temps
assez le point que je le reconnais là
aussi très volontiers ses longues
mort de la décision que nous avions
prise la baisse très forte du coût de
financement pour les sociétés de dot
donc je pense qu'il est impératif pour
les prochaines concession de pouvoir le
réévaluer pour que le bénéfice non
concessionnels ne bénéficie pas d'une
sur rentabilité d'où ma proposition de
clause de rendez vous tous les cinq ans
qui permet de réévaluer le taux de
retour sur investissement cible je pense
que c'est la leçon principale elle
paraît très technique aide en fait
financièrement absolument capital que
nous pouvons tirer de la privatisation
des sociétés de tourner un petit
complément monsieur le président si vous
me permettez
est ce que le gouvernement envisage un
nouveau plan d'investissement de relance
autoroutier dans le cadre des réflexions
qui sont menées et est ce qu'il y a des
contraintes environnementales qui
seraient imposées aux sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroutes ou pas ou
dans le plan de relance monsieur le
rapporteur
la priorité absolue ira aux mobilités
douces et au transport ferroviaire
donc le mobilité douce c'est ce qui
était évoqué par ministre hier sur les
pistes cyclables le soutien aux vélos je
pense qu'il reste beaucoup à faire je le
dis devant les sénateurs parce que vous
êtes les représentants des collectivités
locales et que c'est avec les maires les
collectivités locales qu'il faudra bâtir
ça on peut faire de l'investissement
très important sur les réseaux de pistes
cyclables sur l'accès au transport par
vélo
l'autre volet c'est le transport
ferroviaire et le fret ferroviaire on
n'est jamais arrivé soyons honnêtes à
avoir des plans fret qui soit
véritablement efficace
nous y travaillons avec la sncf et ça
peut être je pense en termes de mobilité
décarbonée
un des atouts forts de la france nous
sommes capables d'investir massivement
dans le fret ferroviaire dans le
transport ferroviaire dans les petites
lignes ferroviaires mais dans le cadre
du plan de relance les investissements
autoroutier ne font pas partie
aujourd'hui du plan de relance
merci merci terminé pour l'instant donc
je me tourne vers nos collègues
christine lagarde a demandé la parole
merci pas si parfait parce que ma
question est exactement dans la
continuité des derniers propos
vous avez dit que vous étiez un usager
de la roue de l'autoroute je suppose que
vous empruntez une des autoroutes que
j'emprunte aussi très régulièrement qui
actuellement fait l'objet de travaux
d'investissement dans le cadre du
précédent plan de relance au tout
routier qualitativement boffin quand on
a un viaduc en trois éléments
mais si bien que cette autoroute va
largement gagné en compétitivité en
rapidité avec son élargissement à trois
voies la wave n'y était pas et dans le
même temps la ligne ferroviaire
concurrentes elle a toujours faim voilà
une très loin d'être niveau top qualité
si je peux le dire comme ça en plus il
suffit qu'ils aient un train qui tombe
en panne toute la ligne et arrêtez donc
comment est-ce qu'on peut rendre compte
donc déjà aujourd'hui la route était en
terme de temps quasiment compétitive par
rapport au train pour aller dans les
principales métropoles régionales de
cette grande région qui est la normandie
demain il est fort probable que la
compétitivité de la route sa manière
donc comment est ce que vous pouvez
répondre à ça sachant que j'entends très
bien votre le souci du gouvernement de
développer le fret ferroviaire il ya
qu'à voir le nombre de camions qui sont
sur cette autoroute pour faire de la
desserte est est ce que le fret
ferroviaire peut trouver sa
compétitivité sur finalement des
distance aussi courte avec des moments
de transbordement qui prennent du temps
et des sillons de fret qui sont mauvais
donc voilà que comment est ce que c'est
ça finalement le futur et c'est quelle
place doit prendre la route dont va là
c'est pour compléter ce que vous avez pu
lire précédemment
merci christine monsieur ministre alors
tout cela est en cours d'examen je vais
décevoir mme la sénatrice mais je n'ai
pas la réponse à sa question
je suis un usager régulier de
l'autoroute a13 que j'imagine que c'est
cette autoroute que vous faisiez
référence je partage chacun des mots qui
a été dit pas sénatrice aujourd'hui
quand je me rends dans ma
circonscription je prends plus la
voiture que
trains ceux qui vont à rouen on met
autant de temps pour ne pas parler du
havre dont l'ancien prêt ministres
edouard philippe parlerait beaucoup
mieux que moi
et chacun sait que la normandie est la
région qui est la plus pénalisée de
toute la france en matière ferroviaire
s'est dit et des sujets vous connaissez
parfaitement notamment le ne demande qui
est très compliqué à régler
moi je reste favorable l'amélioration
massive du transport ferroviaire à
destination la normandie ces
investissements qui sont très coûteux
donc ça fait partie des sujets que nous
sommes en train d'examiner pour voir si
c'est réalisable dans des délais rapides
parce qu'il s'agit bien de relance
économique aussi donc il faut c'est en
effet très rapide sur l'économie mais je
pense qu'il ne faut pas baisser les bras
sur la desserte ferroviaire de la région
d'ambert
merci jérôme bascher merci monsieur le
président c'est le ministre je me
souviens bien mais des discussions
effective en 2006 et gentiment distrait
100 milliards d'euros pour le mystère la
culture à partir des privatisations
d'autoroute donc je me souviens bien de
ces sujets mais vous avez dit une chose
importante
ce n'est plus à l'état aujourd'hui de
construire des autoroutes
moi je l'entends en fermant parfaitement
mais pourquoi ne pas avoir poussé le
raisonnement à l'époque où est-ce que
c'était envisagé sur une partie des
routes nationales où une partie du
réseau francilien qui restent
aujourd'hui sous le contrôle de la dir
ile de france alors même que finalement
ce sont des autoroutes da proche de
paris et qui aujourd'hui vous le savez
bien léché le ministre parfois peuvent
créer des bouchons et sont aussi celles
qui sont les moins bien entretenues en
vérité je ne sais pas pourquoi on ne
pousse pas aux autoroutes franciliennes
pourquoi vous n'avez pas poussé
également sur les routes nationales
deuxième question c'est la discussion
qui me fait penser pourquoi ne pas
envisager ainsi l'état n'est pas le bon
constructeur est le meilleur garant de
l'entretien courant de faire la même
chose sur les voies ferrées finalement
nous avons un retard considérable sur
l'entretien des voies ferrées tous les
rapports l'ont montré ce qu'il n'y a pas
là un sujet finalement de privatiser
aussi les voies ferrées pour faire des
concessions ou qui permettrait de
reconstruire des lignes de faire payer
au moment où arrive la concurrence sur
le réseau merci et jérôme monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole pour
peut-être sur les constructions
autoroutières qui ait pas d'ambiguïté
dans ce que j'ai dit moi je considère
que ce n'est pas à l'état de gérer des
autoroutes de s'occuper des aires
d'autoroute des bandes d'arrêt d'urgence
de l'équipement de sécurité
ça ce n'est pas son rôle il reste des
bars autoroutier à construire la l'état
une responsabilité avec les régions que
les régions qui nous écoutent ne pense
pas qu'on va se désengager
à sa demande le projet où il reste des
barreaux à construire qui sont
importants pour la vie de beaucoup
beaucoup de nos compatriotes
ensuite sur les voies ferrées
l'ouverture à la concurrence déjà fait
soit circulation des trains en revanche
je pense que tous ses actifs sont
absolument stratégique pour le pays et
donc ils doivent rester dans les mains
de l'état
michel dagbert je vois que ça
ce doigt se lève merci peut s'avérer par
le jeu ministre votre réponse concernant
l'infrastructure ferroviaire me va très
bien on peut avoir comme ça quelques
positions divergentes chers collègues
sur cet aspect et pour revenir au sujet
des concessions autoroutières
j'entends bien l'argument qui est le
vôtre et je pense que la puissance
publique doit être en capacité
d'orienter un certain nombre de choix
d'infrastructures de les calibrer en
quelque sorte aussi parler du passage à
trois voies de circulation sur l'a13 et
de l'infrastructure très lourde en
matière d'ouvragés d'art et notamment le
viaduc pour autant le sujet si on accède
à l'idée que l'état n'est peut-être pas
le mieux placé pour gérer dans le temps
de telles infrastructures mettons il
faut qu'ils se dotent de moyens et la
régulation vous l'avez dit doit encore
être améliorée si j'ai bien entendu
votre propos mais pour que la régulation
puissent opérer de manière satisfaisante
il faut encore que l'état conserve en
son sein une ingénierie à la fois
techniques juridiques et
économiques budgétaires de ces questions
pour pouvoir discuter avec des
entreprises dont on connaît aujourd'hui
la puissance à en la matière et vous
avez notamment fait référence aux
contrats et à ce qu'il peut en coûter
lorsque de manière unilatérale l'état
prend une décision tellement les
contrats sont passé moi l'expression
mais d'un point de vue juridique bien
ficelé et donc il m'apparaît peut-être
opportun que l'état conserve une
certaine ambition en matière
d'ingénierie en matière de moyens pour
être en capacité d'avoir une régulation
qui s'opère de manière satisfaisante
de ce point de vue là n'est-il pas
souhaitable que nous gardions y compris
en matière d'exploitation une partie je
dis pas tout ou partie mais une partie
fusse-t-elle infime mais qui nous permet
d'avoir en notre sein au niveau de
l'état des référentiels de coût qui
permette d'aller à la discussion et à la
construction des futurs contrats
merci michel et monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole
et ensuite nous reviendrons vers
tourneront de nouveau vers notre
rapporteur ce ministre oui il ya deux
types d' expertise il ya effectivement
l' expertise d'ingénierie qui relève du
ministère des transports et vous avez
raison on a besoin de garder une
expertise d'ingénierie pour s'assurer
que les contrats sont bien réalisés moi
je suis capable de vous dire si
financièrement il ya eu une
transformation de la rentabilité qui
fait qu'on peut réviser le contrat ça
c'est mon rôle de mes finances
mécha bien incapable de vous dire si en
terme d'ingéniérie des ponts des
chaussées des aires d'autoroute
les choses sont faites correctement donc
il faut garder une ingénierie dans ce
domaine là qui nous permet d'évaluer le
bon respect des contrats sur le plan
opérationnel en particulier sur la
qualité des investissements je pense que
c'est un atout considérable pour la
france d'avoir des infrastructures de
transport de grande qualité
dans des autoroutes qui je le redis sont
parmi les meilleurs au monde d'avoir un
réseau ferroviaire qui est de grande
qualité
le tgv est un atout considérable avoir
des lignes de proximité ferroviaire de
bonne qualité est un atout considérable
comme demain j'insiste là dessus ce que
je sais que c'est un débat mais ça me
paraît absolument vital être en avance
au déploiement de la 5g sera pour la
compétitivité notre économie la création
d'emplois le désenclavement des
territoires
l'installation d' usine dans des
communes rurales un point capital
moi je veux bien qu'on me dise et j'y
crois profondément je suis élu de la
ruralité d'un département rural qui est
département de l'eure mais vous ferez
pas venir une grande entreprise
industrielle vous ne maintiendrait pas
une grande entreprise pharmaceutique
comme gsk à evreux si vous garantissez
pas ces entreprises qu'elles pourront
faire circuler leurs données y compris
des plus lourdes dans des délais 10 fois
plus rapides qui seront données par l'a5
g
ces entreprises iront là où il y en a
cinq il faut voir les choses en face et
si nous les privons la 5g
si nous privons les territoires ruraux
de ce déploiement de la salle g et bien
en accentuera la désertification rurale
et on ratera la réindustrialisation de
la france en moi je considère que la
réindustrialisation de la france est une
priorité absolue et qu'elle est à portée
de main que si nous investissons
notamment dans les infrastructures et
c'est le débat que nous avons
aujourd'hui qu'elles soient matériels ou
dématérialisés avec la 5g nous
réussirons la réindustrialisation de
notre pays et moi je me résigne pas à
voir que la france en vingt ans est
passé de près de 20% de sa richesse
nationale dans l'industrie à 12%
là où elle est restée à 18 % en italie
et où les monter à 20% en allemagne
c'est un combat je crois collectif pour
nos territoires et pour la souveraineté
française
en revanche le volet financier
c'est effectivement le rôle de la
cellule expertise direction générale du
trésor pour l'ingénierie financière des
contrats et de la dgccrf pour veiller
aux décisions tarifaires et aux
questions de rentabilité
et là je crois qu'il est pour répondre
précisément à votre question essentielle
là aussi de garde une expertise
technique très pointue pour nous assurer
qu'il n'y a pas de survente habilité
dans l'exécution des contrats
merci de nous vole donc la parole à
notre rapporteur
oui alors deux questions complémentaires
et qu'il demande d'informations de
questions la première c'est sur les
modifications
décidée sur la fiscalité qui peuvent
bénéficier aux sociétés concessionnaires
d'autoroutes
je pense au cce l'époque qui a bénéficié
est maintenant à la baisse du taux de
l'is puisque il un programme de baisse
jusqu'à 25% du tout liesse qui est prévu
c'est quand même des contribuables à
l'impôt sur les sociétés qui sont
importants et qui vont bénéficier très
largement de cette réduction est
forcément augmenter leur rentabilité est
ce que vous pensez qu'on peut demander
des compensations ce soit sur le plan
des tarifs ou de travaux je ne sais pas
à cette baisse dont ils vont bénéficier
deuxième question j'ai compris que vous
n'étiez pas partisan
de revenir sur sur ces privatisations
qui coûterait 45 ou 50 milliards
aujourd'hui qu'il faut laisser des
contre allées jusqu'à leur terme et qu'à
ce moment là a priori vous seriez
toujours partisan de remettre en
concession
ces 9000 kilomètres d'autoroute à votre
avis sur quelle durée
si vous avez dit que les durs étaient
trop longues sans doute que c'était une
erreur d'avoir maintenu ses durée aussi
longue qu'elle serait à votre à votre
avis la durée optimale sachant que le
gros des infrastructures seraient
toujours en bon état puisque normalement
ils sont censés remettre les sociétés
concessionnaires sur auxerre met les
autos dans un bon état de fonctionnement
donc à partir de là
compte tenu des investissements et des
la maintenance qu'il faut réaliser
quelle serait la bonne durée des
concessions qui pourraient être faites
le dernier point cessé les demandes de
communication de documents que j'ai pu
faire à votre ministère et à vous-même à
trois reprises je sais mais la période
était un peu chargé
14 mars 4 mai au 15 juin et qui n'ont
toujours pas reçu de réponse à ce jour
est-ce que la réponse est en cours de
préparation
et est-ce qu'on a des chances de la
pouvoir la recevoir avant la sortie de
notre rapport qui est prévue pour le 20
septembre
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre vous allez avoir la parole pour
apporter ces dernières réponses nous
arrivons au terme de notre audition vous
avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président d'abord sur
la communication des documents nous
allons évidemment faire diligence mais
je pense que c'est dû une période qui a
été particulièrement chargée pour mon
administration sur la question de la
modification de la fiscalité
effectivement je vous confirme que nous
avons engagé une baisse du taux d'impôt
sur les sociétés qui doit l'amener à 25
% pour l'ensemble des entreprises d'ici
c'est une baisse qui va bénéficier à
toutes les entreprises
nous demandons pas de compensations
spécifiques aux entreprises françaises
on le fait pour la compétitivité fiscale
française
donc il n'est pas prévu de demander des
exigences supplémentaires aux sociétés
d'autoroutes à raison de cette baisse du
taux d'impôt sur les sociétés soit
question de la concession je pense que
c'est deuxième sujet absolument capital
le premier vous l'avez bien compris
c'est la question du taux de retour sur
investissement et des clauses de
rendez-vous régulière pour éviter la sur
rentabilité pour les concessions
autoroutières la durée elle est
absolument capital je pense que la durée
précédente était trop longue
donc moi je plaide pour des durées de
concessions plus courte avec des clauses
de rendez-vous régulière durée de
concession
s'il n'y a pas d'investissement massif à
faire parce que ça dépend évidemment de
la nature des investissements
mais prenons une autoroute sur lesquels
d'investissement très importants
auraient déjà été fait je veux qu'elle
n'y a pas d'investissement massif prévu
dans les années à venir
dans ce cas là une durée de 15 ans avec
des clauses de rendez vous tous les cinq
ans donc trois clauses de rendez-vous
pour éviter l'assurance habilité me
paraît quelque chose de raisonnable
il peut y avoir des autoroutes sur
laquelle il reste des investissements
plus importants a fait donc
l'appartement où il ya des
investissements plus importants il faut
une durée plus longue
pour amortir ses investissements mais je
plaide effectivement pour des durées de
concession de plus courte
ça doit être expertisée avec les
transports mais je pense que c'est une
des leçons que nous pouvons tirer aussi
nous poursuivons donc nos auditions du
jour sur les concessions autoroutières
en entendant monsieur alexis kohler qui
fut l'un des protagonistes de la
négociation du protocole signé en 2015
entre l'état et les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroutes dans le
cadre du plan de relance autoroutier
monsieur colère en effet a conduit les
négociations avec les sociétés
d'autoroutes
alors qu'il était directeur de cabinet
du ministre de l'économie monsieur
emmanuel macron aux côtés de madame
elisabeth bornes alors directrice de
cabinet de madame ségolène royal
ministre de l'écologie du développement
durable et de l'énergie
cette audition est diffusée en direct
sur le site internet du sénat
elle est également ouverte à la presse
et fera l'objet d'un compte rendu publié
monsieur le secrétaire général donc je
vous remercie de nouveau de vous être
rendu à notre convocation et après avoir
rappelé la non menées dans le cadre
vraiment très formelle de la commission
denquête qu'un faux témoignage devant
une autre commission denquête est
passible de peines prévues à l'article
aux articles 434 13 14 et 15 du code
pénal et je vous invite maintenant à
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité levé la main droite
et dit je le jure je le jure merci donc
avant de passer la parole à notre
rapporteur vincent de l'est qui vous
posera des questions précises comme à
son habitude et aux membres de la
commission denquête qui vous
interrogeront tour à tour je vous
propose si vous le souhaitez bien sûr de
nous présenter à titre liminaire dans
quel contexte
vous êtes intervenu en 2014 2015 et avec
quel mandat
vous avez la parole monsieur le
secrétaire général merci beaucoup
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur de la sénatrice monsieur le
sénateur j'essayerai de ne pas être trop
long je souhaitais juste planter le
décor par quelques mots d'introduction
très bref pour rappeler le contexte dans
lequel je suis intervenu comme vous
l'indiquiez votre commission denquête a
souhaité m'auditionner et comme vous le
savez le principe de séparation des
pouvoirs ne me permet pas de répondre
aux questions qui porterait souvent
d'exercice auprès du chef de l'état et
vous demanderez le voilà prêt merci
sur l'exercice auprès du chef de l'état
de mon mandat actuel de secrétaire
général de la présidence de la
république et je ne saurais évidemment
déroger à ce principe dans le cadre de
cette commission denquête pas plus que
dans tout autre mais bien évidemment je
me place à votre entière disposition
pour répondre aux questions relatives à
mes fonctions antérieures en tant que
directeur de cabinet du ministre de
l'économie de l'industrie et du
numérique dans la période comprise entre
la fin du mois d'août 2014 et la fin du
mois d'août 2016 votre commission
d'enquêté l'occasion le rappeliez il ya
un instant d'auditionner la ministre de
la transition écologique et solidaire
la ministre a présenté de manière
détaillée des circonstances et des
conditions dans lesquelles l'état a
remis à plat des relations est une
société concessionnaire d'autoroutes
dans le cadre des négociations
contractuelles aussi bien que dans le
cadre d'un projet de loi voté par le
parlement au mois d'août 2015 je tenais
contrôlable a souligné que je souscrive
est en tout point aux déclarations de la
ministre le ministère de l'économie
entre 2014 et 2016 alors que j'ai exercé
les fonctions de directeur de cabinet
est intervenu aux côtés et en soutien du
ministère de l'écologie du développement
durable et de l'énergie dans ces travaux
trois raisons en particulier expliqué
cette implication
tout d'abord
alors que le ministère de l'économie il
intervient traditionnellement pas
directement dans les négociations avec
les sociétés concessionnaires
d'autoroutes sont l'implication se
justifier par ses compétences au titre
de l'homologation des tarifs et 2
contres signataires des décrets
approuvant les contrats de concession
sachant qu'il n'est pas signataire des
contrats eux mêmes deuxièmement suite au
rapport de la cour des comptes de
juillet 2013 je crois que vous en avez
vous avez l'occasion d'en parler au
cours de vos travaux
la cour estimé que les relations entre
l'état et les sociétés concessionnaires
était déséquilibré est recommandé pour
cette raison il égard à l'ampleur des
enjeux financiers
une implication plus forte du ministère
de l'économie et c'est donc dans ces
conditions que le gouvernement de
l'époque avait souhaité comme ministre
et ses services puissent apporter leur
expertise est connue économique et
financière et leur a demandés nous a
demandé de participer plus directement à
la négociation en cours
et puis troisièmement s'agissant plus
globalement de la question de la
régulation et du cadre de régulation des
concessions autoroutières
le ministre de l'économie de l'époque
avait souhaité porter dans un projet de
loi dit croissance une réforme inédites
et de grande ampleur du 2-2 cadre de
régulation en s'appuyant sur les travaux
de l'autorité de la concurrence
auxquelles je viens de faire référence
j'en viens à présent à l'objet même de
votre commission
au moment de ma prise de fonction les
relations entre l'état et les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroutes étaient
particulièrement dégradée alors que le
président de la république de l'époque
avait souhaité engager dès le début de
son mandat
un plan de relance autoroutier trois
évènements suscité des tensions
croissantes entre l'état et les sociétés
concessionnaires
tout d'abord la décision de doubler la
redevance domaniale en 2013
décidée par l'état mais dont les
sociétés d'autoroutes avait demandé la
compensation intégrale par voie
contentieuse
ce contentieux a paraissait mal engagée
sur le plan juridique
compte tenu de son impact sur
l'équilibré économique des concessions
se déposition des jeux aux finances du
conseil d'état bien connu en la matière
ensuite le débat sur le modèle des
concessions autoroutières par la cour
des comptes en 2013 puis par l'autorité
de la concurrence en 2014 a entraîné un
débat qui initialement porter son niveau
de rentabilité des concessions
autoroutières particulier société
historique privatisée en 2006 vers un
débat devenu éminemment politique et
polémique allant jusqu'à évoquer une
remise en cause du modèle même des
concessions une possible dénonciation
des contrats en cours voire une
nationalisation des sociétés
concessionnaires il a aussi suscité des
réactions très vives des sociétés elles
mêmes
et puis enfin en décembre 2014 le
ministre de l'écologie du développement
durable et de l'énergie de l'époque a
annoncé de manière unilatérale un gel
des tarifs à compter du 1er février 2015
ce qui s'est traduit par l'annoncé
immédiate par les sociétés
concessionnaires de l'ouverture d'une
nouvelle procédure contentieuse qui
s'ajoutaient donc la procédure
contentieuse sur la redevance domaniale
c'est donc dans un contexte très dégradé
que le gouvernement de l'époque a
souhaité engager une négociation tandis
que préalablement l'assemblée nationale
décidé de son côté de mettre en place un
groupe de travail présidé par de mémoire
le cône plus président de la commission
du développement durable de l'époque la
décision d'engager cette négociation a
été prise après une analyse approfondie
du scénario de résiliation unilatérale
qui aurait exposé l'état un triple
risque financier juridique et politique
cette négociation comme l'indiqué a été
conduite par les deux ministères de
l'ecologie d'une part de l'économie
d'autre part sous l'autorité bien
évidemment du premier ministre et de son
cabinet l'enjeu était de remettre à plat
l'ensemble des questions et contentieux
est bien évidemment le défendre au mieux
les intérêts de l'état dans un contexte
qui au départ lui était défavorable
la négociation a démarré tout début 2014
décembre 2014 pardon dans le cadre d'un
mandat fixé par le premier ministre de
l'époque et s'est conclue en avril 2015
après que le président de la république
de l'époque avait souhaité publiquement
en février 2015
je cite un règlement global et définitif
afin de pouvoir engager et lancer
rapidement un plan d'investissement
autoroutier qui s'ajoutaient donc au
plan de relance autoroutier engagé lui
en 2012
le ministre la ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire vous a présenté
les détails de ce protocole mais bien
évidemment nous pourrons y revenir à la
suite de la conclusion du protocole
d'accord de ministère de l'écologie du
développement durable et de l'énergie
on a décliné les termes sociétés
d'autoroutes par sociétés d'autoroutes
dans le cadre des avenants au contrat de
concession
ces contrats de plan permettait à la
fois
premièrement de finaliser le plan
relance autoroutier je n'y reviens pas
c'est un plan à travers duquel en
échange de l'engagement réalisé 3,2
milliards de travaux l'état a accordé
une prolongation des concessions de
leurs deux trois quatre
deuxièmement il s'agissait de définir la
trajectoire des tarifs autoroutiers en
ce compris les hausses tarifaires
compensant le gel de 2015
et troisièmement il s'agissait de mettre
en oeuvre les engagements réciproques de
l'état et des sociétés concessionnaires
parmi lesquels je cite le versement par
la société deux tours d'une contribution
d'un milliard da fit la contribution de
100 millions en fonds de financement
d'infrastructures la mise en place de
mesures commerciales ciblées l'insertion
d'une clause de plafonnement de la
rentabilité le renoncement contention
d'indemnisation la non compensation de
la contribution au financement de l'art
à faire entre autres arguments pour ce
qui concerne le ministère de l'économie
de l'industrie numérique
les travaux se sont concentrés sur la
réforme du cadre de régulation des
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroutes
dans le cadre de la loi croissance à
laquelle je faisais référence
cette loi a créé l'autorité de
régulation des transports ferroviaires
et routiers à partir de
de l'autorité qui existait à partir de
la raf transformant donc lara von arx à
faire depuis lors appelé la rt je crois
vous avez l'occasion d'auditionner le
président je signalerai simplement que
la loi donne trois grandes compétences
aux régulateurs d'une part la régulation
des tarifs des péages puisque la rt
aujourd'hui veille au bon fonctionnement
des tarifs des péages autoroutiers par
un avis sur le projet de contrat de
concession et leurs avenants elle est
aussi consulté sur tout nouveau projet
délégation elle assure un suivi annuel
des taux de rentabilité interne de
chaque concession qui est de mesures
pertinentes de leur profitabilité
nous pourrons y revenir elle établit
également un rapport public sur
l'économie générale des concessions et
annuellement sur les comptes des
sociétés concessionnaires
d'autre part la loi introduit un
contrôle des procédures de passation et
d'exécution des marchés de travaux
fournitures et services
le concessionnaire pour ce faire
l'autorité de régulation du transport
veille à l'exercice d'une concurrence
effective et loyale lors de la passation
des marchés passés par un
concessionnaire d'autoroutes pour les
besoins de la concession
je ne m'étends pas sur le sujet ce point
reflète les recommandations qui ont été
faites par l'autorité de
la concurrence de manière assez claire
et puis par ailleurs la loi prévoit un
contrôle des procédures de passation des
contrats d'exploitation des
installations annexes sur les aires
d'autoroutes
là aussi je ne rentrerai pas dans les
détails puisque c'est le reflet des
recommandations qui avait été formulée
par l'autorité de la concurrence en 2013
j'insiste sur un point supplémentaire
concernant cette cette loi elle renforce
en particulier la formation
parlementaire avec la transmission d'un
rapport quinquennal sur l'économie
générale des conventions délégation et
d'un rapport annuel sur les comptes des
sociétés concessionnaires
elle renforce également le contrôle
parlementaire des concessions
autoroutières puisque désormais toute
extension de la durée des concessions
est soumise à une autorisation du
parlement ce qui est tout à fait inédit
et enfin elle le prévoit des
dispositions concernant le transfert au
secteur privé de société concessionnaire
d'infrastructures de transport
autoroutières dans le cas d'une
concession accordée par là par l'état
qui là aussi sont désormais autorisées
par la loi
pour conclure je souhaite donc insister
sur ce point en particulier car c'est
véritablement la loi du 6 août 2015 pour
la croissance l'activité et l'égalité
des chances économiques dit également
loin de macron qui au fond marque un
tournant dans l'histoire compliquée
mouvementée des relations entre l'état
les sociétés concessionnaires
je crois pouvoir dire que de nombreux
protagonistes observateurs de ces
relations vous diront qu'il ya eu un
avant et un après 2015 en matière de
transparence et de régulation des marché
autoroutier
il en est d'autant plus à l'est ainsi
que la loi a prévu l'application de
nouvelles règles y compris au contrat de
concession en cours à compter de son
entrée en vigueur la période pour
laquelle j'ai eu à connaître la question
des concessions autoroutières me semble
donc avoir permis rééquilibrage des
relations entre l'état et l'état
concédant et des sociétés
concessionnaires comme aussi bien la
cour des comptes
l'autorité de la concurrence et le
parlement la plaie de leurs voeux les
négociations auxquelles je faisais
référence s'inscrivait dans un cadre
contractuel j'insiste sur ce point tout
pour en revenir qui ont donc conduit à
des concessions réciproques mais qui au
bout du compte aura permis à l'état
d'éviter des procédures contentieuses
qui lui aurait été un manque ablement
défavorable et aurait été
potentiellement coûteuse tout en
permettant au gouvernement de
d'atteindre les objectifs qu'il s'était
assigné du point de vue de la de la
relance des investissements comme des
tarifs et la loi est ensuite venu
remettre à plat le cadre de régulation
semble-t-il de manière inédite et
pérenne je vous remercie
chez votre disposition pour répondre à
vos questions
l'accord merci monsieur le secrétaire
général de merci d'avoir fait ce retour
un peu dans l'histoire des au moment où
vous occupiez d'autres fonctions et je
vais demander maintenant à monsieur
vincent collet notre rapporteur de
rentrer maintenant dans cet après-midi
d'auditions en vous il va vous commencez
par vous poser des questions
merci monsieur le président messieurs
secrétaire général merci à pau
effectivement on est obligé de rester
dans l'histoire puisque l'actualité quoi
l'actualité courante et surtout l'avenir
vous ne souhaitez pas vous exprimer
dessus ce que ce qu'on comprend tout à
fait est parfaitement par rapport au
gouvernement et et par rapport aux
fonctions actuelles donc ce qui nous
intéresse c'est effectivement les
fonctions passées de directeur de
cabinet du ministre de l'économie de
l'époque
emmanuel macron et de la façon dont les
choses se sont passées alors vous avez
dit que c'est effectivement ça a été
menée par les négociations étaient
menées de concert avec le ministère de
l'environnement on a on allait à
l'époque un ministre monsieur vie
d'alice qui était en charge des
transports qui a refusé de signer le
protocole et monsieur eckert qui a été
invité à une première réunion et nous
l'a déclaré ici là matignon et qui était
chargée des comptes publics et qui
ensuite a été visiblement écarté des
discussions en tout cas c'est ce qui
nous a affirmé est-ce que vous avez le
souvenir de la façon dont ça s'est passé
pourquoi finalement il n'y a plus que
deux ministères qui se sont occupés de
ces discussions ou voilà qu'est ce
qu'est ce qui a fait que notamment
monsieur eckert qui étaient partants qui
étaient ceux qui souhaitaient pouvoir se
s'associa discussions notamment sur les
aspects fiscaux
puisqu'il ya pas mal d'aspects qui
concernaient notamment la la
déductibilité des intérêts
des empreintes et comme ces sociétés
d'autoroutes emprunte beaucoup et ont
pas mal d'intérêt voilà qu'est ce qui
est qu'est-ce qui a fait que que les
comptes publics ont été écartés ces
discussions alors les comme je vous
l'indiquais dans mon propos introductif
le cadre dans lequel s'inscrivaient ces
discussions entre l'état concédant les
sociétés autoroutières a été défini par
le premier ministre à l'occasion d'une
réunion de ministres est bien évidemment
les négociations ont été suivis au fil
de l'eau par par le cabinet du premier
ministre
très concrètement c'est au sein de
l'état la question des sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroutes et
prioritairement une question qui relève
du ministère enfin du ministre en charge
des transports et donc à ce titre à
l'époque de la ministre de l'écologie du
développement durable et de l'énergie
et je puis vous confirmer que c'est bien
la ministre qui a suivi ces négociations
à ce titre et je ne le je n'ai pas de
commentaire particulier à faire sur la
manière dont la ministre a souhaité
organiser le travail au sein de son
ministère comme l'a souhaité répartir
les l'exercice de ses compétences entre
elle-même et son ministre délégué ou son
secrétaire d'état
s'agissant de par contre à bercy
monsieur vidalis à bercy christian
eckert et secrétaires d'état ou
ministres délégués et je ne peux pas
véritablement vous dire comment est ce
que il a été impliqué ou pas c'est la
responsabilité du premier ministre du
cabinet le premier est d'organiser la
nature l'interministérialité autorisé
cette cette expression il est clair que
au sein de l'ensemble bercy ce compris
les deux ministères de l'époque la
question comme je vous l'indiquais des
sociétés d'autoroutes et de la gestion
des concessions relève plutôt du mit
de l'économie puisque le ministre de
l'économie dispose de compétences
propres à deux titres
d'une part outils de l'homologation des
tarifs et on voit bien que la question
des tarifs était au coeur de la
discussion
et d'autre part parce qu'il lui revient
de contresigner les décrets qui
approuvent les contrats de concession et
leurs avenants mais encore une fois pas
les contrats eux mêmes qui relève de la
seule compétence
à ma connaissance du ministère en charge
des transports
et s'agissant de négociation qui
effectivement ont des enjeux économiques
et financiers qui sont très importants
mais qui ne sont pas annuel au sens où
les dépenses de l'état ne sont pas
engagés au titre annuel on est plutôt
dans questions d'équations économique
pluriannuel l' expertise financière est
plutôt du côté du ministère de
l'économie que du côté du ministère du
budget d'accord et donc vous allez
gossier au nom du ministre de l'économie
de l'époque emmanuel macron elisabeth
borne à négocier
pour ce pour sa ministre ségolène royal
une fois que vous êtes mis d'accord sur
le protocole et avant la signature
il y a eu une note que vous avez rédigé
à destination des ministres pour amant
qui signent le protocole ou comment ça
s'est passé
alors je ne peux vous répondre que pour
ce qui me concerne je peux vous dire que
au sein une dot en commun chacun avait
sa note je raisonnais je pourrais pas je
n'ai pas de souvenir précis
en tout cas ce que je peux vous répondre
c'est que je vous dirais que la fonction
de directeur de cabinet n'est pas
exactement ce que j'appellerais une
profession libérale du que donc à ce
titre il est de la responsabilité du
directeur de cabinet d'informer
régulièrement le ministre auprès duquel
il est de dévolution des dossiers a
fortiori quand il ya une négociation qui
s'inscrit dans un contexte politique
assez assez sensible donc j'ai
régulièrement informé le ministre de
l'époque je n'ai aucun doute sur le fait
que mon homologue au ministère de
l'écologie on faisait de même avec la
ministre de l'époque je crois d'ailleurs
que c'est ce qu'elle vous a confirmé au
cours de cette audition et je crois
pouvoir dire que les deux ministres
avaient le même le même niveau
d'information et que
[Musique]
et que est bien évidemment de façon
assurée l'interministérialité il ya des
comptes rendus réguliers au cabinet du
premier ministre de façon à ce que
puissent aussi en prendre connaissance
c'est à dire que avant la signature il
ya une note de synthèse qui a été de
donner aux ministres pour qu'ils
puissent y ait non je je je pense oui
d'accord je pense quand celui-ci n'est
pas vous qui avez rédigé
ah ben c'est à dire que au sein du au
sein du cabinet du ministre
il y avait une conseillère qui
travaillait également sur ceux sur ce
sujet et les services du ministère donc
le ministre avait à sa disposition
outre le compte rendu régulier que je
lui faisais de l'état des discussions
très probablement pour tout vous dire je
paye le temps ni de loisirs de deux de
faire des recherches approfondies ou de
solliciter les archives de bercy mais je
me semble qu'il est il est probable que
la conseillère en charge en lien avec
les services et avec votre le concours
de votre serviteur et fait une autre
récapitulant le bilan d'une négociation
que il avait donc lavées pousuivre les
les principales des étapes par mais par
le compte rendu régulier en tout
peut-être courrier alors les relations
de
de vous même et d isabelle borne donc
négociateur avec des sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroutes et la
commission parlementaire composée de
députés et de sénateurs qui avaient été
mises en place fin décembre courant
décembre
et quelles ont été ses relations et ce
qui en a eu est ce qu'on n'a pas eu de
quelle façon les choses se sont passées
en fait alors je cherchais là il me
semble que ces versement indus
rencontrer oui tout à fait j'ai le
souvenir
j'ai le souvenir d'une réunion que nous
avons tenue avec le président de la
commission de développement durable et
quelques parlementaires au cours de
laquelle nous avons eu une discussion
sur le cadre général des discussions
entre l'état les autoroutes en
particulier sur la question qui à
l'époque faisait débat 2
la possible résiliation des contrats et
différentes options qui pouvaient être
envisagées jusqu'à la nationalisation
des sociétés elles-mêmes et d'ailleurs
sauf erreur de ma part
le le rapport de ceux de ce groupe de
travail a conduit le rapporteur ou en
tout cas le rapporteur indique que sa
position serait celle d'une mémoire
d'une résiliation et au profit d'un
portage par un établissement public
industriel et commercial qui ont été
nouvellement créé de ces de ces
concessions ont été emmenés une
discussion au cours de laquelle nous
avons expliqué parce que comme je vous
l'indiquais dans mon propos liminaire
avant d'engager cette discussion nous
avons évidemment examiné la possibilité
d'une d'une résiliation et toute une
série de scénarios avec l'aide d'un
conseil financier vu dans les comptes
rendus d'auditions que certains
faisaient réservé référence et nous leur
avons présenté les enjeux juridiques au
regard du droit des contrats et de
l'existence ou non d'un motif d'intérêt
général
les conséquences financières à la fois
indemnitaire dans l'hypothèse d'une
résiliation budgétaire dans l'hypothèse
d'une nationalisation de transactions si
j'ose dire dans hypothèses dans
lesquelles au cours d'une transaction de
cette nature
une concession une société était acheté
à un prix inférieur auquel
potentiellement seraient revendues
puisque c'étaient des scénarios qui
était envisagé les conséquences
économiques également
s'agissant des actionnaires concernés
des sociétés concernées des
investisseurs étrangers concernés et
puis bien évidemment qui est un point
important les conséquences potentielles
pour les usagers et nous devons
présenter de façon moi assez ouverte
l'ensemble de ces de ces enjeux jeu mais
je pourrai malheureusement pas vous dire
exactement à quelle date cette réunion
ait lieu mais je le jure il sung et
cliquez sur complémentaires avant de
laisser la parole aux collègues qui
souhaiterais exprimer
et pour revenir après mon habitude un
petit peu est-ce que vous jugez que le
protocole 2015 était équilibré ce qui
semble dire quoi ce que j'ai cru
comprendre à travers votre propos
liminaires et est ce que si vous
considérez que c'était équilibré ce qui
a quand même des points sur lesquels on
n'étiez pas forcément en accord et sur
lesquels vous avez dû céder par rapport
aux demandes des sociétés d'autoroutes
ensuite la deuxième question ce serait l
équilibre financier des contrats qui est
toujours mise en avant pour dire qu' on
doit toucher à rien
on risque de rompre cet équilibre
comment vous le définissez vous et est
ce que vous en avez une définition à
l'époque sur sur quelle base vous êtes
parti pour vous dire est ce que cet
équilibre est respectée ou pas respectée
et la troisième question c'est sur un
sur le même sujet d'ailleurs du
protocole le fait que ce protocole soit
resté secret qui a décidé qu'il
resterait secret il a été demandé à
plusieurs reprises
alors bien sûr vous allez me dire qu'il
est sorti à travers les avenants et les
décrets qui ont approuvé l'avenant
mais ils sortis au compte-gouttes donc
petit à petit effectivement on a pu
reconstituer
mais finalement pour le relire
aujourd'hui je comprends pas trop
pourquoi finalement il a été décidé
qu'un accord entre l'état et des des
concessionnaires devraient devait rester
secret en tout cas ne devait pas de
communiqué qu'il a fini par devoir
l'être que juridiquement il devait
l'être mais voilà chez ces trois
questions du jeu quel j'aimerais bien de
vous répondre je je pense qu au bout du
compte le protocole d'accord est
équilibré au sens oui le reflète le le
l'équilibré entre les les
les protagonistes de la discussion
j'insiste sur ce point parce que comme
je vous l'indiquais tout à l'heure cette
négociation
l'intérêt dans un cadre contractuel est
assez fort logiquement voulu insister
dans votre dans votre question sur la
question de l' équilibre économique
et effectivement le droit des contrats
en france est extrêmement protecteur des
des partis et au cas d'espèce donc des
sociétés concessionnaires puisque la
jurisprudence du conseil d'état lui
garantit un droit à l'équilibré
économique et
à une une compensation dans l'hypothèse
dans lesquels l'équilibré économique
serait bouleversé c'est la raison pour
laquelle les contentieux avait été
introduit par la société d'autoroute
qu'une fois sur la redevance domaniale
ou sur sur les tarifs à l'époque lorsque
nous engageons cette discussion nous
avons en arrière-plan le risque
contentieux pour l'état et comme je vous
l'indiquais tout porte à penser que ces
contentieux était mal engagée et elle et
conduira immanquablement à se terminer
de manière défavorable aux intérêts de
l'état
au regard de ce que nous connaissions et
de ce que nous indique est aussi bien la
direction des affaires juridiques du
ministère ou le secrétariat général du
gouvernement qui demande une expertise
particulière sur la jurisprudence du
conseil d'état où les avis du conseil
d'état qui avait été donnée quand la
possibilité ou non de compenser d d d
imposition des calmants obligatoires
imposées aux sociétés d'autoroutes
donc le rapport dans cette danse dans ce
cadre contractuel
le contexte n'était pas sur un plan
strictement juridique favorable aux
intérêts de l'état
je pense par ailleurs que il est il est
important quand on engage négociations
de quelque nature que ce soit dans un
cadre contractuel du point de vue de
l'état de toujours préserver la qualité
de la signature de l'état pense qu'il
est important aussi de toujours veiller
à ce que l'état puisse toujours
respecter les contrats qu'il a signés et
que c'est ce qui fait aussi la valeur de
ces signatures lorsque comme à tous
égards y compris comme comme emprunteur
et il en est de vrais de l'état
d'ailleurs comme de tous concédant au
niveau national comme comme au niveau
local
j'ajoute que au delà de ces
considérations juridiques l'état
également était avait des étés de
demandeurs d'un certain nombre
d'avancées et cette affirmer de façon
publique par les plus hautes autorités
de l'état
je pense en particulier aux souhaits du
président république et du gouvernement
de pouvoir conclure un plan de relance
autoroutier et donc de pouvoir engager
les 3 2 milliards de travaux qui par la
suite ont été ont été lancés puis le
plan d'investissement autoroutier qui
est intervenue par la suite comme je
l'indiqué il y avait donc une forme
d'injonction a avancé et apaisée en tout
cas conclure un accord avec les soucis
de haute de façon à remettre à plat et
les questions contentieuses et les
questions économiques et
d'investissement qui répondait à la
volonté
2 le président de la république et du
gouvernement
donc au bout du compte comme j'en ai cas
dans mon propos liminaire au regard de
l'ensemble de ces éléments je les compte
tenu d'un contexte qui n'était pas
favorable aux intérêts de l'état
je pense que le protocole qui comprend
des avancées fortes pour l'état et puis
surtout je reviens sur ce point je suis
tout particulièrement parce que le
ministre de l'époque était très attaché
qui a débouché ensuite sur le vote d'une
loi qui encore une fois de manière
inédite puisque auparavant il n'y avait
pas finalement de cadre de régulation et
de manière pérenne a totalement
renouvelé le cadre de la régulation
aussi bien du point de vue de la
régulation des tarifs que deux points de
vue de l'évolution des concessions de la
durée des concessions des marchés qui
sont conclus par la société
concessionnaire ou des contrats qui peut
être conclue par celle ci une forme de
sous concession sur des déserts de leurs
correspondants alors alors à leur
emprise pour ce qui concerne le votre
dernière question sur la question du du
secret à l'issue de la deûle à de la
discussion
la négociation protocole d'accord avec
les sociétés d'autoroutes
elles ont fait valoir que ça nombre
d'éléments de leur point de vue engagé
le secret des affaires
sachant que il revenait à chacune
d'entre elles demorand de d'informer
puisque du côté des sociétés
d'autoroutes illégalement forme de
représentation on appelle négocier avec
toutes les sociétés d'autoroutes ils ont
désigné de manière informelle
un représentant à charge pour lui de
répercuter l'information auprès de
chacune des sociétés et puis ensuite
auprès de leurs actionnaires dans une
période de laquelle par ailleurs il
avait des assemblées générales
en tout cas je me souviens que c'était
un élément qui avait fait valoir
et donc au regard des moments de secret
des affaires ils ont souhaité qu' il ne
puisse ne pas être publiée tout de suite
et comme vous l'indiquiez du point de
vue de l'état il n'y avait pas dans le
jeu
majeure à l'époque se prennent dès lors
qu en tout état de cause comme l'indiqué
tous les éléments économiques sont en
tout état de cause devait être
retranscrit dans les avenants au contrat
de concession à ce titre faire l'objet
d'un décret en conseil d'état et à ce
titre être être publié donc in fine et
toute l'information évocation être être
public et je ne crois pas aujourd'hui
mais je n'ai pas regardé de façon
suffisamment approfondie ce qu'il y ait
des éléments dans le dans le protocole
qui ne ne soit pas un goût très normal
que l'état ait dit ok c'est le secret
des affaires en comics rien mais in fine
et tout mais j'ai bien entendu sauf que
ça a été publié au compte-gouttes façon
parcellaire un peu difficile à
reconstituer et quand même pour
l'information du contribuable comme de
l'usagé il n'est pas anormal d'avoir une
transparence en dix ans effectivement on
considère que cet équilibre est parce qu
on a des investissements qu'on appose
d'un côté on a des compensations
n'allait des fonds qui nous arrivons
tout ça ça peut ça peut discuter un peu
discuté moi je je je suis un peu surpris
je suis un peu surpris de ça mais bon ce
soir j'ai passé trop de temps là-dessus
moi ce qui m'intéresse plus est votre
définition déquilibre financer des
contrats parce que voulait pas donner
est ce que les services de l'état à
l'époque on évaluer puisqu'il y avait eu
un doublement de la redevance domaniale
je sais plus combien ça faisait moi j'ai
pu en mémoire le chiffre est pourtant la
mémoire des chiffres mais dans
l'occurrence sur la redevance domaniale
ça m'a un peu échappé mais est ce que
c'était vraiment de nature à mettre en
cause des équilibres économiques du
contrat
si c'est le cas ça veut dire qu'on l'a
défini cette union économique du contrat
et pourquoi dans ces cas-là avoir
accepté dans le protocole une clause
disons que tout tout nouvelle imposition
décidée par l'état spécifiquement sur
les sociétés d'autoroutes devrait être
compensée parce que s'il avait ici
c'était vraiment à l'abri d'une
compensation obligatoire pas juridique
en allant devant devant la justice et en
disant l'équilibré rompu
donc dans ces cas là y'a pas besoin de
klose moi je suis un peu surpris par
cela je suis un peu surpris par le fait
que dans le protocole on met cette
clause la et qu'avant on ait peur
finalement qu'ils obtiennent
satisfaction s'il était sûr l'obtenir
7,6 satisfaction il n'aurait jamais
demander finalement une clause ensuite
c'est pas alors je m'occuperai très
honnête je me garderai bien de donner
une définition de l' équilibre
économique qui fait l'objet probablement
de nombreuses thèses et livre de laura
manche en tout cas je pense que la
littérature abondante en la question
d'équilibré économique le droit en
équilibre économique
le fait du prince les conditions
d'indemnisation et je je je
c'est avec beaucoup beaucoup d'humilité
que je voudrais que je serais bien
incapable de vous faire une présentation
détaillée sur le sujet je peux néanmoins
vous dire que vous apportez deux
éléments le premier c'est que comme je
vous l'indiquais à l'époque
effectivement avant de s'engager dans
cette dans cette discussion
nous avions demandé une évaluation du
risque contentieux pour l'état et donc
on se tourne vers les experts de
juridique de l'état qui effectivement
apporte une appréciation sur le fait de
savoir si oui ou non les décisions
prises de manière unilatérale par l'état
sont de nature ou non à bouleverser
l'équilibré économique ou plus
exactement être considéré comme par le
conseil d'état comme bouleversant cet
équilibre économique et donc ouvrant
droit à indemnisation et l'art se sont
excusés m'associant dix experts
juridiques de bercy de l'ensemble du
gouvernement le chaque ministère à sa
direction des affaires juridiques au cas
d'espèce je pense que encore une fois le
ministère chef de file étant le
ministère en charge des transports
parce que
le ministère des transports direction
des affaires juridiques du ministère des
transports une expertise juridique en la
matière de même que celle de bercy parce
que la question des impositions de toute
nature qui de fait vont avoir un impact
sur les concessions d'une pas une
question totalement neuf
mais il ne fait aucun doute que l époque
gg j'ai en mémoire le fait qu'ils nous
avaient été indiqué que le contentieux
sur la redevance domaniale qui avait
doublé puisque on parle d'un passage de
105 ans pas merci 280 à 350 millions
d'euros ce qui n'est pas totalement
négligeable était de nature à conduire
l'état à devoir indemniser les sociétés
je crois que sur la question des tarifs
de la question ne faisait pas
véritablement l'objet d'un débat
juridique et donc la question s'est pas
vu ne se posait même pas sur l'issue
d'un contentieux
le deuxième point faire valoir c'est que
les sociétés concessionnaires
d'autoroutes
à l'époque elle était marquée par trois
débats la redevance domaniale la
question de du plafonnement ou non des
des intérêts au type de l'assiette de la
fiscalité qui faisait l'objet de débats
de mémoire d'ailleurs probablement dès
2012 en tout cas j'ai le souvenir que
c'était un débat récurrent
et puis troisièmement évidemment la
question des tarifs
donc elle dans un contexte dans laquelle
dans l'équipe global de l'accord
outre les éléments que je mentionnais
c'est à dire qu'ils étaient liées au
plan de relance qui était liée aux
tarifs soit du point de vue de gel et
compensation soit du point de vue des
mesures commerciales qu'elles ont
consentis pour le covoiturage pour les
nouveaux cars qui était libéralisé pour
les véhicules propres
et puis j'ajoute que l versée
dans le cadre global de cet accord un
milliard d'euros pour la fuite
c'était un prélèvement supplémentaire
puis 200 millions toute l'infrastructure
je crois que elle souhaitait dans la
mesure du possible avoir quelques
assurances sur le fait que l'état
n'allait pas continuer à prendre des
initiatives de nature fiscale ou à
travers des prélèvements de toute nature
qui était de nature à bouleverser une
fois leur équilibre économique
et comme vous le savez il ya une société
en particulier qui bénéficie dans le
contrat de concession domaniale ab
initio d'une clause paysage fiscal qui
est assez protectrices voit que cette
cette clause a inspiré les autres
sociétés d'autoroutes qui tout à fait
qu'ils ont souhaité que les autres
contrats puissent être amendées f1
devoir s'inspirer de cette clause dont
kiki d'un seul point de vue retranscrit
dans leur contrat la jurisprudence du
conseil d'état et je pense avait une
valeur de réassurance pour les sociétés
d'autoroutes probablement aussi de leur
point de vue à l'égard de leurs
actionnaires de façon à garantir que
certes elle faisait des concessions sur
l'évolution des tarifs certes elle
prenait des mesures commerciales
certes elle faisait un prélèvement de 1
milliard d'euros qui était un
prélèvement volontaire certes elle
apporte une contribution d'un train sur
deux mais que à priori elle pouvait
apporter de la visibilité quand quant à
l'avenir
voilà pour ces auditions que vous avez
pu suivre sur notre antenne
merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette
émission n'hésitez pas à consulter les
articles de la rédaction public sénat
sur notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne suite des programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires
[Musique]